yeah well you lay it out very well Holly
the relationship of religion on both
sides of these types of agenda actually
it's both sides doesn't do it justice
its many sides and religion shakes
itself out on all of these sides to the
particular project of religion and
ecology has found voice in the School of
Management say through Brad Gentry who's
also in forestry you as a again someone
whose musical to the motivational issues
that religion brings to it and Gus path
is also when he was Dean of Forestry and
environmental studies was very helpful
in raising this type of concern for the
business community but this is an issue
that remains to be explored at some
length because there's no way we can
move forward at the depth with which we
need to move forward without the
business community and I think someone
like Dan st in his book green gold is a
green to gold is beginning to explore
some of the possibilities he doesn't
specifically address the role of
religion in this question but he does
raise the question of business and
values orientation and so I think it's
it's happening in the business community
maybe again environmental values would
be the rubric rather than religion but
my overarching comment is I come again
out of study of indigenous traditions
where life way or the sense of
religiously inspired activity penetrates
into the whole of life and I find when
you meet people who are deeply moved by
religion it penetrates into their life
way also and I take many business people
to have that kind of sincere
understanding